so i have a friend who's part of it and
he's an
he runs an agency and i'm pretty sure
it's 60 000 a year so quite expensive i
think it's only two events a year that
they do so it's almost it's basically an
events business and they sold for
hundreds of millions of dollars recently
to uh
pe just like i think a pe company and
then another one is uh aventa have you
heard of aventa
i haven't heard of aventa okay so it's
e-v-a-n-t-a
aventa was sold to gartner for like 250
million dollars and it was almost like
the same thing
but it was worse because it was
advertising driven
the reason why we asked you to come on
is because chief is awesome and we love
community-based businesses and most
community-based businesses have horrible
business models
and from the outside it appears as
though you have from the press and
whatever i can just read about the
internet it seems like you've got a
really good business model and that's
what i wanted to talk to you about today
was that business model because we've
talked a lot about tiger21
and uh ypo is kind of interesting
but uh you guys are like the next kind
of person
attempting this and it seems like it's
working really well and that's what i
wanted to ask about
yeah awesome well uh congratulations on
on the podcast and uh
and was excited to come on and chat
because there's been a lot happening for
us at the beginning of this year so yeah
and before this where were you casper
no that was my co-founder so uh we both
have been in kind of the new york city
ecosystem for a while
um i actually i started the startup
scene at hannah i launched
i launched and ran soap.com uh under
mark lore quincy got acquired by amazon
then went over to south korea and worked
on kupang which is the amazon of south
korea and then
most recently right before chief i was
at handy running operations for them
and my co-founder
was at casper so yeah and when did you
decide when did you go all in full-time
on chief
uh i probably went full in
is when uh officially left uh other
positions and dedicated myself full-time
to this
and uh it was one of those things that i
felt like i had to
do the full commit and actually like put
everything behind it or else it would
just like keep that slow crawl of kind
of an idea um because uh without pulling
putting everything in it it just you
know wasn't making the same progress
that they really needed to make
i do the same thing and i that's what i
tell people uh what what's i think the
phrase is uh i used to say it was
burning your bridges but it's not it's
burning the ship so like there was this
like
kind quesador i forget who his name was
but it's like where he like landed in
america or somewhere like that and
they're like look we have to succeed now
because i just burned the boats so like
we ain't going home
and uh i guess that's the story i don't
know if that's real or not but i i
totally believe that that's the uh
that's the the the way to go about this
and
what chief what did what how would you
describe chief as it is now
yeah so chief is really focused on
senior executive women uh it's you know
under the phrase that we hear so often
of it gets very lonely at the top um but
it gets lonely at the top for women a
lot more
and our mission is really to
drive more women into positions of
leadership and keep them there and and
by focusing on that kind of senior
executive woman
you know our belief is just getting more
of them in true positions of influence
the ripple effect that that could have
across all different companies and
organizations is is really where we
wanted to go and kind of tackle this
first
and i kind of call it like a ypo above
her vps which is basically like
and this is all from the outside
obviously i'm not a member but this is
you basically it looks like what you get
you pay like some sum of like five to
eight thousand dollars a year-ish and
you get and the company pays for it and
you get to meet up with like a core
group of like five or ten different
women or it's the same women um and then
you have like a coach and then you have
the ability to like chat with the entire
group whenever you want online and then
i imagine you have some type of like
programming throughout the month that
you can join as well right is that is
that basically the model
it's it's very very close um so
i would uh ypo definitely was a
inspiration for us for sure um where
they only focus on ceos and presidents
um that is their entire focus
and as a result not surprisingly it's
largely men that are a part of ypo since
that is what the makeup of a ceo and
president
when i think of ypo i think like old
white dudes
it's it's not far off um and it was just
an inspiration for us to say wouldn't it
be great to have an organization like
this focused on women so we're vp level
and above we we also have a lot of ceos
and presidents who are women that are a
part of the organization but we focus on
vp and above
and as you mentioned
probably the
heart of what we do is what we call our
core groups it is this group of ten
individuals we go through a very curated
process of finding the right group of
ten to come together
they meet every month there's an
executive coach in the room and that's
called core for a reason um it is the
heart of the service that we provide but
around that we have all sorts of
different
services and and
and resources that you can tap into so
we have our own programming that you can
attend as much or as little as you would
want to you can tap into the whole
network through our community product we
even have clubhouses in three cities
across the u.s that you can
that you can use so
lots of things that are kind of around
the
around the core experience but that
truly is the heart of what we do
what was the original idea how was it
different than how it evolved into into
what it is today what was the original
premise
i as we did this last fundraise it was
funny we pulled out our seed deck of you
know what we were showing when we were
raising and
it didn't change that much which is kind
of phenomenal you always hear so many
stories of
you know we tried this we needed to
pivot because this wasn't working or
that wasn't working
and the heart of what we wanted to do
was always very much
what it is today i think the biggest
change that we've undergone is
most of our services were all happening
in person when we launched that's the
reason why we had kind of these physical
spaces we had the clubhouses we were
doing core in person
um but with the pandemic everything
moved over to virtual uh which has you
know in some ways been
a small silver lining for us and that
we've been able to you know extend to
more cities faster because we don't have
to do big build-outs and it's actually
even more
powerful and engaging for our members
because this truly is like the movie
trope of the busy woman and now instead
of having to you know trek across
a city to get to a clubhouse to get the
benefit of chief
it's now
in your pocket wherever you go
and at this point did i see 15 000
members is that right
it's
close to 15 000 members yes wow or maybe
it's a third i forget what the pr the
you you guys you whatever you what is
that 13 or 12 whatever it said recently
because you raised 100 million in
funding at a 1.1 billion valuation so
it's like it's a pretty huge business
and
you only launched what three years ago
like launched uh live uh publicly three
years ago
three years ago yes that's crazy right
it is it is i can remember back when we
were launching and we're like we're
going to have just a hundred great
members as we launch and we're really
excited and um even from the very
beginning and the launch that we had um
we had thousands of people sign up for a
wait list for chief and now
yes we're close to 15 000 members um but
we have a wait list of close to 60 000
which is kind of incredible and i think
it just really shows
how much a community like this is truly
needed um and
the value that it's that it's really
creating for our members so let's say
you're at 15 000. let's just say the
average price is 6 000. that's 90
million in revenue i imagine the truth
is like give or take 20 maybe and i
don't know if you say that or not what
it is but regardless
if it's in that ballpark it's a pretty
substantial business in a and such a
that's
let's say 60 to 100 million in recurring
revenue
in three years
that's wild right
it is it is and i think what's really
what i feel so much privilege of on in
any given day when people hear about
chief because it's such a mission
oriented business
um that's what they think of they're
like oh it seems like such a
good business
but great mission
and i don't think that people realize
that it's both like a great mission and
a great business and i think you know we
live in a capitalist society and being
able to have both of those things come
together idiot would say that
you just do the math like it makes sense
like this like
if you scale to like 50 million in
recurring revenue in three years that's
a great company you're probably a lot
higher than that i mean what
uh do they know how to do math do they
can they use a
calculator i don't know i've talked to a
lot of vcs so there still needed to be a
lot of convincing
so when i started the hustle um so the
hustle was my company we sold it to
hubspot when i started the hustle it was
just it was basically just a daily email
and it was relatively easy compared to
what you have started because
the person receiving the email had no
idea if there was a million people or
one people
getting it like that didn't impact their
experience so then we started trends
which is like our subscription business
and that had a paid community and that
sucked because i had to make it cool
before i thought it was going to be cool
so like i had to like convince my
friends to like join and post in it and
like make it seem like a you know it's
like a restaurant that already has
customers before you actually know like
if it's any good
when you so i know these businesses can
be tough for that reason how were you
able to get your first let's say 10 or
even 100 people because it's like you're
selling them something that isn't real
but it only becomes real when they're
sold and bought in and like commit to it
yeah i mean i think that there
um
was a lot of
small tactics that all bubbled up to
you know a a meaningful
investment in the brand that allowed for
people to understand what we were trying
to build and who we were trying to build
it for
um
and
i think we were really fortunate in
having just some really amazing early
members that kind of kept that ball
rolling but it was everything from
you know one of the things that we did
was have a physical space at the onset
and
the physical space in some ways was like
marketing for us to kind of show a brand
that we were trying to develop and um
uh and and really bring that to life uh
we
that was a conscious decision and
investment into the brand things like we
didn't have a social media presence at
all um because uh we felt like
what were you gonna say how would it be
meaningful and it actually helped to
create like this really interesting
tightness of people that were in the
community versus trying to
you know
shout it out into all of the different
social media areas um so there were a
lot of things that i think we did
and ultimately like uh
word of mouth was by far
our entire
acquisition
uh strategy um which was pretty amazing
um
you just emailed like your 10 or 20
closest friends and they probably told a
handful of people and you just said like
hey we're launching this in like 60 days
apply and we'll let you know if this is
a good fit
yeah i mean it was not just our closest
friends we definitely sent some cold
emails out to people that we had never
met before and i remember even some
early
vc conversations where we were showing
you know here's our first members
and they were like oh so are these just
all your friends and lindsay's friends
my co-founder were like actually no
that's not the case um it was it was
amazing a cold email to sea sweet
executives at fortune 500 companies and
people were excited to join i think
being able to
also reference the ypo model which a lot
of people understood
um helped to create some of that
traction
um and even the companies themselves so
our model is one where
you know sell directly to her she then
goes and gets it sponsored within within
her company
um and we didn't know how well or how
easily that sponsorship would go and
companies signed up really quickly i
think for them they look at you know
one-on-one executive coaching can be
thirty thousand dollars for a six-month
engagement so
uh relative to that this was a great way
for them to invest in some of their top
talent
and you got to like i was
like reading i think so you launched i'm
looking at my notes you launched like
around
december 2018
within like a month or two you're you
passed seven figures in recurring or
like a run rate right but you had that
cash in and then by the end of the year
you're nearing 10 million in revenue
i mean that's pretty wild
yeah um we started to sell at the end of
2018 we didn't officially launch
services until 2019 in february of 2019
and we were just in new york city
so we were continuing to add members in
new york city until
around you know mid 2019 we went and
raised our series a largely to expand
into new cities um which at the time was
a more capital intensive way of of
expanding because we were in person we
had to make investments into clubhouses
and so we were
in the midst of those build-outs when
the pandemic happened um and uh that's
when we made the full pivot over to
virtual and as we did that engagement
actually went up across every every one
of our services definitely it was a time
where something like chief was needed
more than ever and it allowed us to
expand in a much different way
how did you know what to tell the
coaches like what what to tell them
how to run their group
or
ypo they've got facilitators uh i don't
know what you call your uh folks but
basically like it's
i've i've done a couple of these things
and they're pretty amazing it's
basically like and some people get
insulted when i say this but it's
basically group therapy
and it's awesome and it's incredibly
necessary
but a good
facilitator therapist like makes or
break it a little bit
they do they do and and we do a lot of
vetting to make sure that we have the
right
coaches that are coming on that act as
we call them guides on our platform um
and they're just fabulous we have close
to 400
executive coaches that act as guides for
us now
and for us i think there's you know a
little bit of a
beginning introduction into core that is
very similar for all core groups in the
first few sessions there's you know a
very prescribed way of bringing the
group together making sure that
everybody creates um
a deep sense of of community even within
that group
and then from there a lot of it really
is for the coach to decide the right
path for that group because every group
is different of what they need and what
they're looking for so we have created a
lot of content but it's to the coach and
the group to really decide which
direction they want to take a lot of
those conversations and
you know a vast majority of those
conversations are real time
dependent on what's happening with the
people in the room of you know if
somebody's about to go through a massive
recon uh you know restructuring within
their company they're going to want to
have a little bit more air time in that
session of people helping them work
through some of those things so
it's uh
it's heavily structured and guided
but with a lot of flexibility depending
on what is needed for each group
so i want to kind of nerd out a little
bit on this on these models on this
business this community business model i
think it's awesome and i actually think
that like
it's with the remote or whatever we are
in now i think it's you're going to see
a lot more of these pop up and i think
you're the first of this like new age
ones but i want to talk about some old
school ones i want to tell you about my
research and you tell me if you've heard
about any of these have you heard of
world 50
i have yes what do you know about world
50 so
you're gonna know of all the ones that i
know plus more and you're the only
person that is able to nerd out with me
on this stuff so that's why i like you
yeah i mean they're all what i have what
i have generally found is that
most of the
communities that existed before now
we're all very focused on the the most
senior people for ceos like the you know
uh
and a lot of what i'm guessing you're
about to list are all that they're all
that i think
yeah
no no one isn't i have one that isn't
okay what's the one that isn't on deck a
lot of people know what on deck is i
don't even think on deck knows what on
deck is i think they're still trying to
figure out like their existence or like
you know their identity but they are
attempting to do something it seems as
though they've i have no inside
information this is all just looking at
their website it seems like they're
they're they're pivoting
into kind of what you're doing
yeah i mean i think
i have deep respect for them as a
company um i think a lot of times what
you often find is there's this
what leads does like community lead or
does like curriculum and professional
development lead um and
i think for them when it's education i
think
i think it's hard it's hard it is it is
um and for us community has always led
um and even you know
you could extend that to many other
paradigms of like just community lean
lead or to space lead like what is the
actual service that you were providing
and for us we knew that community had to
be the thing that always led um
and even if you think about some of the
you know
kind of analogies that you could make
like business school as a as an analogy
like
yes a lot of people think you're going
back for curriculum i don't think you do
i think you go back through the network
and the people um and so
uh for us that has always been the the
major
uh thing that we knew we had to focus in
on and i think you know for on deck i'm
not sure that they lead with community
as much as they do kind of the
programming um
and uh that i think is kind of the
difference that i would see there
so here's a few of businesses in the
space that might like surprise the the
listener so we talked about world 50 so
as i know it world 50 it's basically
uh for cmos i think just cmos right
i thought it was broader than cmos i
thought it was actually more of like ceo
uh
individuals it started as cmos but yeah
i think it's expanded beyond that but
basically i think they were sold so in
the cmo or whoever it is and there's
like agency owners so i have a friend
who's part of it and he's
he runs an agency and i'm pretty sure
it's 60 000 a year so quite expensive i
think it's only two events a year that
they do so it's almost it's basically an
events business and they sold for
hundreds of millions of dollars recently
to uh
pe just like i think a pe company and
then another one is aventa have you
heard of aventa
i haven't heard of eventa okay so it's e
v a and
a aventa was sold to gartner for like
250 million dollars and it was almost
like the same thing
but it was worse because it was
advertising driven so the attendees
would like log on like it would be like
this chief information officer which
frankly i don't even
companies that are i've never worked at
a really big company like in order to
have a chief information officer you're
gonna be a pretty huge company so i
don't even entirely know what a chief
information officer is but they would
host these like webinars pretty much
where like a chief information officer a
bunch of would come and like you know do
like the group therapy thing and explain
pros and cons and like
you know how are we supposed to work
from remote and do all this
whatever they just complain and improve
with one another and all that type of
thing and they would charge like bank of
america or some big sponsor money to be
there and they sold the company to
gartner for like 300 million dollars
it's pretty wild
yeah yeah
yeah i mean
event businesses in general
is a
type of business model that i didn't
really have much familiarity with until
chief and i would never consider
ourselves an event company um
but uh it's been pretty interesting to
see
the opportunities that exist for for
people in that space for sure
what are the i used to own an event
business and we like did like seven
figures in a year on it and it was a
pain in the ass it was so hard it's so
stressful it just like because like
there's not many businesses where like
if it rains you're screwed like if it
rains one day out of 365 days like
you're you're poor
yeah what
what opportunities you see with events
well i mean i think that there's all
sorts of different um
angles that people have created in in
that world and you know i think a lot of
the content businesses have even started
to you know try to extend into that a
little bit more but
you know like summit series i think was
just like a really interesting model of
what they were trying to create had a
lot of community within it um but you
know again it was more events-led than i
think community-led um so it's been an
area that
uh we definitely pay attention to um
because it feels
related but uh not in our exact
wheelhouse for sure
have you heard of um vistage this is
just is an interesting one too right
yeah yeah vistage is basically like ypo
um
they focus specifically again on that
ceo and president profile
um i think they're close to like a 200
million dollar business uh i heard that
they're doing 100 million in profit a
year
that's what i heard from a relatively
trusted source but i i don't have proof
uh of that
would that would that surprise you
um
i think that
if if you look at
some of those business models so let's
take visage or you take ypo
um you know why po is a non-profit um
and
yet
uh
might be one of the most profitable
non-profits i would imagine um because
what we have is our biggest expenses you
know we have these spaces we invest
heavily into our coaches we do a lot of
that stuff
for ypo they actually don't have
paid facilitators they train members to
be the facilitators of a lot of those
groups um so
it's an interesting model to to think
about
and
uh what are you imagining
that as a as a part of that they they do
pretty well um but i've never seen their
financials so i cannot speak with
authority on
either of those businesses wait why po
you've never seen
no no i've never seen it's public isn't
it can't you just log in and because
it's a non-profit
yeah they bucket things in ways that i
think makes it pretty difficult to
really discern what's underneath each
thing um so uh
not fully able to break that down
right
are you guys
as chief
were you able to run it mostly break
even or will you lose it a lot in order
to get big fast because
it seems like it worked
um i would reframe the the
latter statement to say
uh we
were spending to make the experience as
strong as possible i wouldn't say that
we were spending to grow
faster like i said most of what we and
how we have grown has been through word
of mouth so we haven't had to you know
continue to just pour money into a
marketing cycle
um
but for us particularly over the
pandemic and everything else we wanted
to make sure that we were really
investing in the member experience and
and continuing to do that and we're
continuing to do that and that's why we
wanted to raise more capital to continue
to do that
um
and you know i
i think about
when brands are are made and yeah and
it's in those tough times and for us
being able to be there for our members
through the pandemic when a lot of them
at the very beginning of the pandemic
there were furloughs there were all of
those things like how do we invest in
that experience over that period of time
was really important to us
if an employee
if one of your members
quits or
leaves their
job
do you just have a team that will just
like holler at their new employer and be
like hey uh you know ashley was a member
of chief her you know ibm no longer pays
for it
and then you like you know somehow like
get in with that company a little bit
yeah i mean i think that is actually one
of the other reasons that we wanted to
go and raise this money is that right
now it is a b to c to b business right
like we develop the relationship with
her she then goes and gets it sponsored
and
what we have found is that when she asks
the sponsorship has actually been pretty
easy to get um yeah it's a no-brainer
but the barrier is her asking um and so
us going and actually building more of
those relationships directly with the
company it seems like a no-brainer for
them to proactively do more of this
instead of reactively approve um and so
i think that's a an opportunity for us
to explore to really take that burden
off of her to to have to go and get that
sponsorship
um
but uh
you know we we definitely
you know 20 of the workforce changes
jobs in any given year so there's
definitely a lot of new relationships
for us to help
both the companies and the members
navigate
we're talking about tiger 21 and it's
cool so tiger 21 is basically uh you
know a community for people who have i
think above 10 million liquid net worth
and that's cool that's pretty sexy just
hanging around rich folks all the time
that's great but it's actually kind of a
tough sell i would imagine because it's
the person paying for it and when i
heard about chief
um i was like oh my gosh this is like
you know when i
our company when i sold we were only 40
employees and so we were probably just
crossing that threshold where we could
afford to send only a couple employees
to like things like this and i was
thinking about like my leadership team
like man if one of them come came to me
and asking for this like this would just
be like the easiest of like yeah yeah
totally i would probably make them sign
like a deal like it says like all right
but if you quit within a year like you
owe us like some you have to reimburse
us but uh i was like yeah this is this
is just an easy sell for chief i
understand why this company's going to
get so big
yeah yeah i mean i think we've
definitely heard stories where when
there has been like
that the
there's some companies who i think are
like well you're going to go in and
you're going to meet new people and that
could actually open up new opportunities
for you that you may not otherwise have
and it's actually the exact opposite
what we have found is
when a company says no on on the
sponsorship
it is a really clear signal to a lot of
these people that okay you're not
investing in me you're you're you're you
don't value me and so that is actually
the trigger of somebody thinking about
going and leaving and finding other
opportunities and so they will
self-sponsor and go and find something
versus be sponsored be happy in the job
that they are and continue to grow as a
leader for that company
what other uh you know you're focused on
your thing but
a lot of times what we do here is talk
about ideas so things that we may or may
not do but it's interesting based off
the intel that i know
what other
niches or opportunities do you like this
business model for
yeah i mean i think that
uh
this business model in particular
is one that i think will
have a really interesting next few years
as
people are still working from home and
still in this hybrid world but wanting
that community and those connections and
so i think in those in any area where
that feeling of loneliness is is
still really present coming out of the
pandemic i think there's some really
interesting opportunities i think the
hard part is the the nice the really
nice aspect of chief is that ultimately
it's the company that can sponsor it and
so how do you find those areas and those
demographics and those people who need
that community who will crave that
community but have somebody like the
company that's willing to make that
investment in those people and that's
the one-two punch that i think makes
chief really
interesting
and
harder to find outside of like the
professional sphere
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot
grow better
yeah well i was thinking about this
model and i was like it makes perfect
sense for
this group because i was like uh you
know we have a problem with uh women not
there's you know it's not equal in terms
of like the representation so like of
course i would invest in this in order
to uh help my folks and in doing so like
whenever you have a group that feels
like they're like
disrespected or like they're they don't
like how they're being treated they bond
together in a great way it's like us
versus the world like you know that like
mobilizes them and that type of every
great community is based on that and i
was thinking about like well if you just
did this for like
just anyone like let's say like i think
there's a company called ven wise have
you heard of ven wise
yeah yeah and i think it's basically
just what you're doing but for everyone
and i'm like well that's
why is that succeeding and why is chief
succeeding and not been wise and those
or they are probably succeeding but
they're probably no nowhere as big and
impactful as you guys um
it's because that like this idea of like
it's us versus the world that type of
you need that in any type of community i
think to in order to mobilize one
another and to feel
bonded
yeah i then wise i think focuses in on
um
senior executives probably like c-suite
executives and high-growth startups
that's like their their focus so um
and
uh i think a lot of what they do
uh really focuses in on that peer group
model solely and doesn't have a lot of
the community
the broader community around it it
doesn't have that shared mission um and
i i would potentially reframe what you
said just a tad to say like i don't know
that it's as us versus them as much as
like a galvanizing mission that brings
you together that just makes you feel
really bonded um
and it doesn't have to be at somebody
else's expense but it is a a feeling of
togetherness that is created and i think
that is what um you know the the mission
of chief really does allow for is that
that broader connect connectedness
within the community yeah that's what i
did i didn't mean like uh i said us
versus the world but it was it's
definitely it's not like we're trying to
kick anyone's ass it's like uh
you know not everyone can identify with
how we feel finally i'm i'm amongst my
tribe and others don't exactly
understand
uh yeah you know vistage could be cool i
think vistage is i think vistage i think
their whole like shtick is uh la it's
kind of like blue calories so like
someone who owns like a moving or
plumbing company that does like 10 or 20
million in revenue and and that person
to themselves probably says like i feel
alone like you know i don't i don't hang
out with people like me i need to find
like my people um
and so like it's like that uh
finding your your tribe maybe is a
little bit better than us versus the
world
yes exactly um it is that feeling of um
if i don't have a group of people that
understand my context easily
and finding that being able to
be able to tap into that
and to be able to have the
confidentiality that goes with some of
that too because a lot of what happens
in these peer groups
is
you know pretty raw honest authentic
conversations that is is hard to have
with just anyone
how are you as a founder able to get
intel and insight into your customers
and your product because i bet you're
you don't go to some of these groups i
mean you don't go that would that
wouldn't be great to have you uh you
know like the big boss and a bunch of
these groups so like how are you able to
learn quickly and figure out what's
working and what's not
yeah i mean i
we do not it's a it's a confidential
space for them to have their
conversation so we're not able to you
know watch what is happening in each of
these sessions
but i think you know even going back to
what we were just talking about of
there being a
galvanizing feeling around this mission
our members are just so passionate about
this mission that they are not shy to
give us feedback on anything and
everything um so
uh we
it is truly been
kind of a an amazing experience to be
able to
get all of that feedback and be able to
create some of this
in partnership
and we have some amazing members who
have stepped forward and
you know we have one member who's like
i'm going to just run a sub board
services community group within chief
and bring in speakers and help each
other find opportunities and so you've
just seen such a
uprising of both
feedback but also really big
interest in in stepping forward and
helping to create stuff together
so for one of our communities we have
like 15 000-ish paying members sort of
like you have but like not even close to
the the the amount of revenue but a lot
of people
but we um and like the hardest part in
terms of like tactics for starting a
community is that i found
is getting people to participate online
and it's like literally like just the
friction and so a lot of the things that
i've done i've built stuff like so many
things so many i've built a bunch of
different communities on facebook groups
because i have never seen a platform get
or a community platform get as much
engagement in terms of um people
it people in the group
uh the ratio of people in the group to
the ratio of uh people in the group to
people who participate in the group but
then a lot of people i've seen like i've
got a couple friends that have huge
blogs and they just go you know let's
just say like one of these blogs is
financial samurai financial samurai.com
personal finance blog it's awesome he
was like oh i'm just going to create a
forum on my website financial
samurai.com forum and even though he's
got this huge audience the forum is
crickets and it's because like literally
going to that website and posting on a
forum is in like it's like a .01 percent
like ratio of people in the community
and readers
to
participating whereas facebook i've
found it to be like if you have 100
people in the group like 10 or 20 people
will actually participate which is
pretty astounding have you been able to
crack that code with getting people to
log in and go to your website and making
it all happen
and participating yeah
yeah absolutely so um
we we started early days in a pretty
similar tactic um candidly of
where are they already and how do we you
know not create that additional friction
of needing to go to
our proprietary you know app website etc
um and so we actually started early days
on slack
and it was
amazing to see the amount of interaction
that was happening there and and how
much uh people were
you know stepping forward to help each
other to connect to all do all sorts of
different things the problem is that
like slack is definitely not built for a
community of oh man
sucks i hate it
you can't you don't even know who you're
talking to unless they properly filled
out their pro like it's just not the the
forum and so we switched over to ours
our own in in 2020
um
and it has sustained um and i think for
us a lot of it is around you know
there's like these known touch points
that are going to come up you're going
to
every month you're going to have a core
meeting that's going to pull you into
the product in order for you to go and
get what you need to get to go and have
that conversation um and there's many of
those types of things that you know
there's there's many utilities that
exist within the platform that pull you
in and then once you're in draw you into
a lot of the community aspects um so
it's been really great to see um and
it's everything from you know i
it
i'm looking to hire somebody to i need
an employment lawyer like there's just
so much need and for you to have a
vetted network to be able to tap in to
do that you can't really do that on a
linkedin um at this point because if
your linkedin is like mine
i know like 20 of the people that i'm
connected to at this point
um and so it's a really valuable utility
and resource that we've been really
excited about how much people have
engaged in it and it's not just to go on
and doom scroll and you know look at our
content it's actual utility for them
what i'm about to say kind of sounds
like a backhanded compliment but it's
not it's it's very much a compliment but
basically you guys have created this
brand
the reason it sounds bad is because i
was gonna use the word like elitist but
that's not fair i don't mean like
elitist in the bad way maybe elite like
just like badasses you know like it's
it's like harvard or something where
it's like it's hard to get into
there's not much on the internet about
it you guys i don't think you have a
twitter or a facebook or an instagram
you only have linkedin and so like
there's this thing where it's like
i don't know if you like to admit it but
it's like fomo where it's like oh man
like the cool peop the people who i want
to be are part of this thing
uh i want to be part of it
but i can't you know i got to get
accepted
how do you how do you go about creating
a brand like that on purpose is this
something that came natural to you like
how how do you make this where it's like
uh so
i mean you just executed that strategy
well
yeah yeah i mean we
uh
we like to think of ourselves as vetted
we are a vetted community we're not an
exclusive community we're not an elite
community but we are vetted because
um
so many of the people that are members
de facto fall into the mentor position
or you know the manager and so
really for it to be a beneficial
community for her it has to be vetted
for people that are more her peers
um
and
you know i think that there is a
level of
aspirational branding that we wanted to
to create with chief because
candidly if you think about
even like three years ago as we were
building this if you heard the term a
women's professional network
you would not think of something
aspirational it would be like
warm white wine name tags and pantsuits
like that is what would be like in your
mind of what a women's professional
network was and so it was really
important for us to create something
that
felt
um like we were celebrating our members
instead of what so often a women's
professional network gets created into
and that was why you know we talked
about that at the beginning of this that
was why we wanted to have a
space that felt um that that brought
that brand to life that helped to
showcase what we meant by that and
um and the space really allowed that
brand to come through it's why we didn't
want to be on a lot of those social
networks i think my my co-founder and i
were talking about like a social media
strategy we're like what are we gonna do
just put inspirational quotes out there
like every week um like we've seen that
like how do we make this feel different
um and so
it was very important for us to really
create a brand that we thought our
members deserved
how do you think this story is going to
earn uh end in terms of like uh
are you gonna is someone gonna buy you
do you think that like a linkedin would
buy you you think you want to go public
what do you
what's gonna happen five or ten years
down the line you think
uh i think that we are excited to keep
any and all option open um but at the
end of the day
um
the entire value of this organization is
our members um and so and it's
our members are here because they are
they need the value that we create but
they also care deeply about our mission
and so anything that we do any partner
that we you know want to um talk to any
strategy that we go and enact has to be
very much in line with that mission
and i've been very fortunate
in going the vc route that we've been
able to find the right partners who can
come on as those vcs that understand
that that leads everything and anything
for us would you want to be ceo of a
public company
[Laughter]
uh
it has never been on my bucket list of
things that i feel like
i'm craving to do
um but i want chief to be
as successful as it ever could possibly
be
and
i want there to be
a great outcome for our members our team
etc um and
that leads more than anything
well this is awesome um
this is this is really intriguing you've
you haven't done a ton of podcasts i
think right
no we have we have our own the new rules
of business by chief but uh i've not
been
uh on many podcasts as a as a guest do
you think uh good and i noticed that and
that's why i wanted to talk to you do
you think that um
you're just so under the radar for i
think how the the the uh
there are so many other businesses
in our little circle jerk startup world
it's kind of full of stupid hype and
there's so many of them that are
we talk about so much but they're like
kind of [__] like not good companies
and they're gonna go nowhere but then
you folks are the exact opposite where
you're like seeing like you actually
have a pretty substantial business i
think it's going to be actually
incredibly big
very few people are talking about you
you know what i mean and i i find that i
i kind of think that's actually cool and
i want to know how do you how does that
make you feel
i'm right where i want to be
i i i think that there's actually
something really amazing about um
being
under
you know uh
hyped um i i really
like kind of
making sure that we are focused on the
most important thing which is like
building a great business and not like
and even for lindsay and i you know uh
as co-founders
um part of the reason why we don't do a
lot of you know publicity and other
things is because we
are actually trying to showcase our
members more than ourselves like they're
actually a hell of a lot more impressive
than either of us are
um and so it feels it feels right for
what we are creating um to be heads down
and focus on building a great business
versus
you know uh
building hype
yeah well it's awesome where are you
from
where were you raised i
uh grew up in ithaca new york
area okay so you
so and where's your co-founder from
also upstate new york but like
new york city upstate new york like an
hour not my true upstate new york
well that's badass i'm uh i'm i'm happy
we got to talk i think it's amazing what
you guys have accomplished you're you're
under the radar i think and the reason i
wanted to talk to you was i noticed not
a lot of people had talked to you and
it i don't know i feel like maybe uh i
could like uh i take a little bit of
pride in like we spotted this winner not
quite early on he already raised money
at a billion dollar evaluation but like
uh
maybe maybe maybe a billion will be
considered quite early for how the story
ends though so uh
uh i'm really appreciative that you guys
uh that you decided to come on and give
me a give me a shot
yeah no i was excited to come on and and
have the conversation and
um like i said i think a lot of people
i remember very early days of even just
trying to get a lawyer to like help us
establish the company and like
yeah was talking about wanting to be vc
funded and i literally could not get a
lawyer to
work with me because they were like this
should not be a vc funded business this
is a very nice you know lifestyle
business so like i can't even get a
lawyer hey
do this
so it's it is nice to be able to
you know celebrate some of these wins
and um
and for people to know that we
have a deep mission but it is a great
business too the lawyers wouldn't talk
to you and you're happy that you're able
to like celebrate this win
yeah uh so yeah we i couldn't even pay
lawyers to to represent us um so it's
nice to have these wins and be able to
you know not only show that we're a
really mission oriented business but
we're a great business too and i think
that's first of all i hate when people
say it when they say oh this is a knife
this is a nice lifestyle business i hate
that for
a
they're they're trying to insult you and
be insulting a little bit and b they're
wrong because
lifestyle businesses are like
what
what does that mean it's a lifestyle
business oh like it's just a company
that can make like 20 or 30 million
dollars a year in profit and i could
just own it all yeah then it is a life
like yeah
like a lifestyle but what's that mean
like like like
i don't i don't know like mars candy
like a family-owned business that's like
the largest company in the world yeah
sick lifestyle so i i cannot stand when
they say that i think that's really
stupid but
with your with your business i do think
i'm like
man i would want to be greedy and own
the whole thing i wouldn't want to raise
money and so is there any do you think
do you think you'll have regret about
raising money or at least about raising
as much money as you have because
the business model is
pretty freaking perfect like it's like a
pretty efficient amazing model i think
yeah i mean i think that there is a a
definite strategy that businesses like
ours could have of going very slowly and
using proceeds from the
the business to
feedback into the services that you want
to create that's definitely one way that
the strategy could go
um
i think
i
i do not think that i would have any
regret with the the way in which we are
going um
because i think we're impatient of
trying to build a really meaningful
powerful network for badass women that
that that need this um and you know at
the heart of the mission is like to
drive more women into positions of
leadership and keep them there
it's over 200 years before we get to
gender parity in senior executive
positions and if a little bit of
dilution means that we can go and
execute on that mission faster
i'm
game i understand why people invested
you're very good at your pitch you've
have it honed in you you seem like a
force to be reckoned with
congratulations on everything uh i'm
happy i got to speak with you thank you
uh for coming on do you
do you use social is there any is there
any uh thing that you want to plug like
you're you're i don't even think i saw
you using social did i
yeah i'm not i'm not as much of a social
media person as my co-founder uh i'm on
linkedin but um yeah i think the thing i
would plug is is our podcast as well the
new rules of business by chief which we
just launched last year and so people
want to check that out they they can see
us there
how's it going podcasts are pain in the
ass to grow aren't they
it's fun though i actually like i every
single uh podcast episode i'm kind of
like this is like a nice little
learning experience for me too you're
just talking with like experts in their
fields and
learning a ton through it that i'm
really enjoying it
i think it's fun to do so at the hustle
when we so we are required by hubspot so
we don't have advertising anymore but
before we were advertising berta make
money and when that was the case
it was
very tough it was very hard and because
it was like all right how do we get
downloads up how do we get downloads up
for you folks like maybe because you're
not making money directly from it it's
still important to get big or whatever
but it's not like you know you're not
gonna go hungry uh and so yeah if i was
in your position i would think it's
awesome as well
yeah that is true that we are not a
advertising led podcast business i
appreciate it thank you yeah thank you
this was fun
[Music]
you